Have gas, so finally the exam hall, what has to be done,
examination hall, keep this garden closed,
now we have to take care only of the exam, there is
no debit even on the story,
first we have to go to the washroom, wherever we have to go,
whatever we have to do, everything.  After doing this, sit down as soon as the
instructor means your examiner blows the horn,
listen to his instructions very carefully.
If you get the answer sheet in your hand, then immediately start
filling in your details and put all the answers
in the seat.  If you prepare the answer sheet, then
you will have to do these tips in the examination hall,
then we will tell you how to do it
[Music]